Joe Thomas has introduced as 10 time Pro
Bowler but he's six-time all-pro like
you want to be six-time all-pro more
than you'd want to be 10 time Pro Bowler
I would think the pride of Wisconsin Joe
Thomas joining us the former Browns
offensive tackle so if I say 10 time Pro
Bowler would you rather I said six-time
all-pro you can say whatever you want
just don't call me late for dinner
why I saw where you're losing weight so
you maybe you uh maybe you don't want to
be called to dinner what's the deal here
you lost a lot of weight and I think
typically guys go one way or the other
when they retire and I was always kind
of a small guy trying to keep weight on
during my career so it was pretty easy
losing it and I was pretty happy to be
able to shed some of those pounds and
let the joints feel a little bit better
do you feel different well I feel a lot
different I feel a lot better I mean can
you imagine taking a 50-pound backpack
off your back and being able to go up
and down the stairs every day no problem
now if you played offensive tackle today
at your weight what would happen there
would be a lot of cut blocks there'd be
a lot of Holdings there's probably a lot
of sack and what are you now 33 I'm 33
yep ain't it weird to like now what do
you do you retired do you have any
hobbies like what are you doing with
your life now Joe I've got a lot of
stuff going on I've got a lot of hobbies
I've got a lot of other interests
looking into the broadcast media space
and I've got three and a half kids at
home so they keep me busy on a daily
basis actually I make it now wait is mom
pregnant mom is pregnant she's doing
like two weeks oh boy did you did you
have big kids they were average size I
would say you know seven and eight
pounds right in there oh okay
I mean that's that's a that would be a
breakfast for you when you were playing
for the Browns right that was that was
one burrito
how are the Browns looking to you there
mister hard knocks
I think they're looking great I'm
excited about all the new weapons they
got on offense I think the Tyrod Taylor
Baker dynamic has really been great so
far and I expect that to continue
anything tyrunt's the perfect guy to
help mentor but also still be the leader
and be the guy that's behind the center
so that's exciting I mean I'm I'm
anxiously waiting for Josh Gordon to
come back and see how that changes the
office but I think even if he's not back
anytime soon I think they can really
score a lot of points on office this
year if you were still playing offensive
tackle for the Browns who would you want
to start week one as your quarterback
I've always said this that I think
experience is underrated at the
quarterback position so I would
definitely go with Tyrod I think I
played with a lot of rookie quarterbacks
and a lot of times they look great in
practice they look great in the
preseason but once you start throwing
stuff at them that they haven't been
coached up that week they have a hard
time and I think playing quarterback a
lot of times what happens during the
course of a season as you're falling
back on some of the experiences that
you've had early on in your career
whether it be defensive coverages or
blitz packages or how you're going to
handle certain blitz pickups and if you
don't have those experiences to fall
back on a lot of times that's when big
negative plays happen and that's what
you see a lot from rookie quarterbacks
how often did you go into a game
actually thinking you could win well to
be totally honest in later on in my
career as the losing sort of piled up I
didn't really even think about that I
just kind of focused on my job and
trying to win my individual battle and I
just focused on how can I be perfect in
this game and give my team the best
chance to win because I didn't want to
think like a fan because I knew that
would lead to a decrease in my own
performance because I was distracted
with something that I had no control
over we're talking to Joe Thomas the
former Browns offensive tackle I'm
looking at this dynamic between Todd
Haley the offensive quarter Greg
Williams the defensive coordinator and
they look like two lunatics out there
Joe I think it'll be great I've been
around Drake for
last year and I've never been around
Todd except for my interactions with him
this spring but offensive defensive
coordinators always have a little
good-natured back-and-forth in training
camp because of the competitive nature
of training camp and I've seen them
coming after it a little bit I don't
know if I've ever seen it good blows but
definitely pushing and shoving and I
think it's just a normal part of
pre-season and kind of going through
that but as soon as the regular season
starts they're in the same team and
they're all rolling the boat in the same
direction what do you think about Dez
Bryant adding him to the roster that
would be interesting I'm not sure to
where he does it physically obviously he
hasn't had the amount of interest that
he expected Dallas obviously you know
something and there's a reason to take
got rid of him they know him better than
anybody so I'd be cautious but I think
at the right price it could be a hungry
veteran that could add some good
leadership good experience and some good
play making ability to the room as fans
what should we take out of a preseason
game like what's real and what's not I
would say almost everything's fake I
don't know what you can take out of it
at the fan I mean maybe you can fool
yourself and be excited if your team
wins but I wouldn't do that if I were
somebody that knows much about the game
yeah that's what we're trying to figure
out like watching Sam Donald or you know
Baker Mayfield against the Giants you
you we we love to overreact certainly
with rookie quarterbacks in the
preseason
yeah my rookie here Brady Quinn was our
first round pick with me and he started
or I think he started like the fourth
preseason game against the Bears will
right down the field we scored a
touchdown and everyone's thinking and
you know the next Peyton Manning and
nothing against Brady at all but when
you're in the preseason we look back at
the film and they played cover to
legitimately the entire game so he kept
taking the middle throw through the
running back which is as everybody knows
and cover to is always open so they
don't adjust in the preseason you're not
gonna see that ever happened in a
regular season game so it's just not
even apples to apples when you're
talking about a regular season in a
preseason game because preseason they're
just gonna let you take whatever you
want
they've got a few things they want to
work on in the game and they're just
gonna let the chips fall where they may
and that'll never happened in the
regular season
good Brady Quinn out Ben Chu there is no
doubt especially now I'm kind of weak
right now I lost a lot of weight what is
the funniest thing that ever happened in
the huddle is you never missed a snap so
you were there for just about every play
funniest thing that ever happened was
when Josh Johnson came into the huddle
maybe a week after we signed him and
nobody in that huddle knew who knew his
name because did you ever help up a
court I don't think you gave up how many
sacks did you give up in your career did
you ever pick up did did you ever pick
up the quarterback and just say my bad
after your guy got him I have it yeah I
had a rule I would never pick the
quarterback up because even if it was my
fault I felt like it was still a little
bit his fault so he should have a little
bit of that and get himself up I think
the over-under is five wins on the
Browns this year what do you got I got
the over over all day see so you got him
at like six wins you know I said I've
had him at eight
Wow a little while I like that right now
you know there's still obviously a lot
of pre-season and we haven't seen him
with real bullets but I really like what
they did in the off season and I think
it is a really solid number I still feel
good about it I'm curious from an
offensive line perspective when you have
these different quarterbacks you'll have
mobile quarterbacks you've got guys who
extend the play like Brady is sort of
the anomaly if you look at a guy who's
41 who doesn't have that you know
explosiveness or athleticism as an
offensive lineman would you rather block
for Brady or would you rather block for
Russell Wilson well I'm great
quarterbacks but I'd rather block for
Brady because you know where he's going
to be at all times and so it makes your
job easier because there's an offensive
lineman you're almost never looking at
the football you're always blocking for
whoever has football so you kind of have
to go off of what the play says and your
instincts on where he's going to be okay
like Russell you're gonna try your
hardest to block as long as you can and
to hope you know where he's gonna be but
a lot of times he's gonna end up in the
spot you don't think and he doesn't get
creamed from time to time by your man
because you just have no idea you're
blocking for a spot you can't see out of
the back of your helmet
you didn't miss any snaps what was the
bathroom situation like you know it's
funny I sweat so much in games that I
never really had to pee I mean maybe at
halftime I was going in pee but if I had
like an ID or two before the game I'd
probably pee at halftime but there was
never any time where I was worried about
you know missing a snap because if I had
to run to the bathroom did you eat at
halftime oh yeah I actually ate
throughout the game we had these little
like Gatorade shoes and these other like
power bar like goos on the sideline for
calories because you burn so many
calories like you're the blood sugar and
everything is getting really low during
a game your glucose your glycogen so you
got to kind of keep that up to be able
to keep performing at a high level did
you ever take anything was anything
personal on the field that you took off
the field with a player you know what I
don't think anything ever went off the
field but I was most upset when a guy
would think that he got the best of me
when he really didn't you know what I
mean like the the quarterback steps up
in the pocket and starts to run and your
guy makes a sack and you hadn't blocked
for six seconds and it was really the
quarterback just going to run that he
made him allowed him to get the sack and
that was what bothered me by far the
most where a guy would jump up and start
dancing around when he did absolutely
nothing on the play
did you say anything I usually said
something like hey buddy anybody could
have got that sack including my grandma
I blocked your ass for six seconds you
did nothing wow that's some serious
trash talk there Joe you dropped grandma
in there you're crazy
[Laughter]
Hey you you you big bully my grandma
could have got that is that sort of how
it sounded yeah yeah it was something
like that yeah I like to come off the
top rope on these guys I love it I love
him hey good to talk to you and good
luck here in the next couple of weeks
there all right thank then appreciate
you having me all right Joe Thomas
joining us from Madison Wisconsin one of
my favorite cities former Browns
offensive tackle for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]